the Russian president's military
escalation was sharply criticized by
Western leaders at the United Nations
General Assembly President Biden and U.S
allies accused Putin of targeting
Ukrainian civilians and slammed it for
suggesting that nuclear weapons are an
option Nancy Cordes was at the U.N for
the president's speech yesterday is with
us now in the studio Nancy first good to
see you good morning
good morning Gail President Biden
addressed world leaders just after he
learned that Vladimir Putin was
mobilizing hundreds of thousands of
reservists he called the move extreme
and outrageous and his aides described
it as an act of desperation
Russia has shamelessly violated the core
tenants of the United Nations Charter
with Russian representatives in the room
President Biden called out their
President Vladimir Putin President Putin
has made overt nuclear threats against
Europe now
Russia's calling up more soldiers to
join the fight even as he spoke unrest
began to Ripple through Russian cities
conflict dominated his first meeting
with the UK's new prime minister Liz
truss Mr President protests are breaking
out across Russia was this mobilization
a miscalculation
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
also addressed the assembly Wednesday
and did not hold back we must finally
recognize Russia at the state of sponsor
of terrorism in a pre-recorded speech he
demanded the global Community hold
Russia accountable even calling for the
creation of a special tribunal a crime
has been committed against Ukraine and
we demand just punishment Under Pressure
Russian separatists abruptly released
two U.S military veterans who were
captured more than three months ago
while fighting alongside Ukrainian
forces Andy Nguyen and Alex drewke both
from Alabama were part of a prisoner
swap CBS News spoke with druki's Aunt we
are so grateful to the Ukrainian
government for
taking up their calls and treating them
like one of their own and we pray for
all of the Ukrainian pows there are
hundreds
I asked the top White House official how
this new Russian mobilization might
affect the war right now and he said the
Russians are stuck if they send these
new troops to the war right away they'll
be too poorly trained and equipped to
fight effectively but if Russia takes
the time to train them then it will keep
losing territory in the meantime he
argued time and math are not on their
side Nate
Nancy thank you